incendiando neumáticos disparando al
aire y gritando así protestaron al menos
un centenar de integrantes del grupo
armado Phantom 509 de la policía exigen
que el gobierno actúe frente a los
asesinatos lesiones y desapariciones de
policías a manos de bandas
delincuenciales
necesitamos una Revolución habrá un baño
de sangre Si el Primer Ministro firme un
pacto con los bandidos muchos policías
están muertos y no han dicho nada ni
siquiera un tuit por los agentes
asesinados estamos en las calles para
luchar por nuestros hermanos y hermanas
que son victimizados por los bandidos
saldremos a las calles cada día hasta
que consigamos lo que queremos
los manifestantes atacaron la residencia
personal del Primer Ministro Ariel y el
aeropuerto de la capital haitiana
acusan a las autoridades de inacción
frente al actuar de las bandas
delincuenciales que según la estimación
de Naciones Unidas controlan el 60% de
la capital después de Dios está la
policía estamos aquí por nuestros
policías los ciudadanos aseguran que la
violencia de las pandillas ha aumentado
dramáticamente desde el asesinato del
presidente Joel Moisés en 2021 sumiendo
al país en una espiral de Caos y
violencia aún más profunda
según la ong red Nacional para la
defensa de los Derechos Humanos 78
oficiales de la policía han sido
asesinados desde que Ariel asumió El
Poder en julio de 2021 muchos de los
manifestantes piden la renuncia del
Primer Ministro cuyo mandato consideran
ilegítimo